قال وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين امير عبد
الله ان التواصل بين بلاده والغرب مستمر
بشان احياء الاتفاق النووي وذلك بالتزامن
مع تاكيد مصدر ايراني مطلع للجزيره التوصل
الى تسويه مع الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه بشان احد المواقع التي تخضع لتحقيق
الوكاله حول وجود جزئيات اليورانيوم
المخصصه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما دلاله اعلام وزير
الخارجيه الايراني بشان استمرار التفاوض
مع الغرب حول ملف بلاده النووي وما مغزى
توقيت هذا الاعلان وما طبيعه الرسائل
المتبادله بين واشنطن مع واشنطن بشان هذا
الملف
وما السياق الاقليمي والدولي الذي يجري
فيه تبادل الرسائل بين طهران والغرب بشان
المفاوضات الخاصه بعوده الاتفاق النووي مع
ايران وما افاق التوصل الى حل لازمه
الاتفاق النووي الايراني في ظل هذه
المعطيات وعلى اي نحو سينعكس على المشهد
الدولي وعلى دول المنطقه
[موسيقى]
في اجواء ضغط عليها انباء نجاح صفقات
تبادل الاسرى واخبار عن مفاوضات تنخرط
فيها الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه
بشان امكانيه الافراج عن سبعه مليار دولار
هي اول ايران المجمده فيسول اكد مصدر
ايراني مطلع للجزيره التوصل الى تسويه مع
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه بشان احد
المواقع التي تخضع لتحقيق الوكاله حول
وجود جزئيات اليورانيوم حيث كشف المسؤول
عن موافقه طهران في مارس اذار الماضي على
اعاده نصب كاميرات مراقبه في احدى منشاتها
النوويه على ان لا يتم ارسال معلوماتها
للوكاله الدوليه وانما يجري تخزين هذه
المعلومات في شرائح خاصه
ضمن هذه الاجواء الايجابيه بشان ازمه
الملف النووي الايراني جاءت تصريحات وزير
الخارجيه الايراني حسين امير عبد الله
هيان التي قال فيها ان طهران مستمره في
تبادل الرسائل مع واشنطن بشار عوده
الاتفاق النووي عبر وسطاء في المنطقه وعبر
الاوروبيين كما اضاف الوزير الايراني ان
المفاوضات مع الاتحاد الاوروبي في هذا
الشهر لا تزال متواصله وانه على اتصال مع
مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيف بورال بشان الملف النووي
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من طهران
محمد صالح صدقيان الباحث المختص في
القضايا الاقليميه ومن واشنطن الدكتور
جوزيف
سيرينسيونيه وهو عضو المجلس الاستشاري
لوزير الخارجه الامريكي سابقا وينضم الينا
من الرياض سالم اليامي المستشار السابق في
وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه اهلا بكم جميعا
في هذه الحلقه وابدا معك في طهران استاذ
صدقيان يبدو ان الكثير من الامور تجري تحت
السطح بين طهران والغرب ما دلاله ما كشفه
وزير الخارجيه الايراني عن هذه الاخبار
الان
مساء الخير لك ست خديجه والى ضيفيك
وللمشاهدين ان يعتقد بان طهران تريد ارسال
رسالتين من هذا التصريح الذي اطلقه اليوم
حسين امير عبدالله عيان الرساله الاولى هي
ممارسه الضغط او المزيد من الضغط على
الاداره الامريكيه
المتلكئه في احياء الاتفاق النووي
وبالتالي هو يريد ان يقول للمجتمع الدولي
لخمسه زائد واحد بان ايران مصره على احياء
هذا الاتفاق وان هذا الاتفاق على الرغم من
انسحاب الولايات المتحده منه في العام
2018 لكنها
تعتقد بان هذا الاتفاق ليست اتفاقا ثنائيا
وانما اتفاقا دوليا تم بينها وبين اعضاء
مجلس الامن الدولي الاساسيين في مجلس
الامن الدولي اضافه الى المانيا وبالتالي
ايران تريد احياء هذا الاتفاق او بالاحرى
تريد ان تستفيد من هذا الاتفاق لاننا نعلم
بان هناك استحقاق ينتهي في سبتمبر ايلول
القادم
وهناك استحقاقات لايران بناء على ما ورد
في اطار الاتفاق النووي وبالتالي ما يقوله
وزير الخارجيه الايراني امير عبدالله هيان
هو يتحدث ايضا في ظل اجواء التفاؤل
والاجواء الايجابيه التي تسود العلاقات
الايرانيه الاقليميه سواء كان مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه مع مصر مع بقيه دول مجلس
التعاون الخليجي خصوصا في ظل الزياره التي
قام بها سلطان نعمان هيثم بن طارق الى
طهران يوم امس وبالتالي كان هناك حديث حول
الملف النووي والقضايا الاستراتيجيه التي
تربط ايران بالاقليم وبالعلاقه مع الدول
الغربيه وتحديدا من الولايات المتحده
الميزاج في الغرب
استمعت الى هذه اللغه التفاؤليه التي
يتحدث بها الاستاذ صدقيان باي مزاج تستقبل
هذه الاخبار في الغرب
انا لست متفائلا الاشارات حتى الان
ايجابيه لكنها ضعيفه وهناك الكثير مما
ينبغي عمله قبل ان نقترب من استئناف
الاتفاق واعادته الى الحياه فيما يتعلق
بمشكلات النشاطات ايران النوويه الماضيه
تدور حولها تصريحات ايران وايضا تحقيقات
الوكاله الدوريه للطاقه الذريه هناك
عراقيل ينبغي ان يتم تجاوزها هي ليست ذات
علاقه مباشره بالاتفاق النووي لكن لها
علاقه بالدعم داخلات المتحده لاي
استئناف لان الاتفاق لدينا شخص امريكي
محتجز في ايران وايضا ردود فعل ايران
العنيفه ضد المحتجين على الحكومه وايضا
دعم ايران لروسيا فيها هجماتها على
اوكرانيا يوم الاحد فقط راينا 50 مسيره
ايرانيه تستخدم في مهاجمه كيف عاصمه
اوكرانيا كل هذه الامور تجعل من الصعوبه
بمكان المتحده ان تستانف انت ذكرت هذه
السلبيات لكن الا ترى ان التسويه مع
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه في حد
ذاتها يعتبر شيئا ايجابيا الا تراه
ايجابيا
تذكروا ان كل ما لدينا هو الاعلان الصادر
من ايران ليس لدينا اي تصريح صادر عن
الوكاله الدولي للطاقه الذريه لا ندري هل
الوكاله ترى فيه تطورا ايجابيا او لا حتى
لو فرضنا انما تقوله ايران صحيح تماما
فهذا يجيب على سؤال من بين اربعه اسئله
اخرى ما تزال عالق نعم هو تطوري ايجابي
جيد اعتقد ان ايران قامت بهذه الخطوه لان
مجلس امناء الوكاله سيجتمعوا في غضون
اسبوعين
وايران تريد تفادي اي اعلان يدينها يستر
عن مجلس امناء الوكاله ربما هذا الاعلان
يرمي الا التخلص من ايه ادانه مقبله
لايران لكن لا يعنينا نقترب من اي اتفاق
ابدا طيب نبقى دائما في سياق استقراء هذا
المزاج حول هذه الاخبار الاستاذ اليمين
يعني
التسويه مع الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
ثم الحديث عن التواصل مع الغربي باستمرار
التواصل مع الغرب حتى وان كان عبر وسط هل
هذا ينعش التفاؤل باحتمال تصفير المشاكل
تحديدا في الملف النووي برايك
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم احييك استاذه
خديجه وحي الساده الضيوف والاستاذ دكتور
محمد واحيي ايضا السيدات والساده
المشاهدين يعني انت سالتي سؤالين الاول
يتعلق بعلاقه ايران بوكاله الطاقه الذريه
الشيء الاخر
وجود الوسطاء وما يسمى في العلاقات
الدوليه بصناديق البريد التي ممكن ان تنقل
الرسائل بين الاطراف التي بالعاده يكون
بينها احتقان ونعرف انها هناك اكثر من جهه
دوليه منظمات ودول بينها وبين الجانب
الايراني احتقان انا من وجهه نظري يعني
الاتفاق يعني كل ما نظرنا اليه نحن ننظر
الى الوراء بمعنى انا لا ارى ان هناك شيء
في الامام انا لنا نظرتين للوراء النظره
الاولى الى 2015 وهو ما تريد ايران ان
تعود الامور الى 2015 وان ترفع يرفع الحظر
عنها
وان يكون هناك ضمانات لاستمرار الجانب
الامريكي في هذه اللقاءات هذه ايران خربت
علاقاتها بالجانب الاوروبي منذ انطلاق
الصراع في اوكرانيا قضيه
الصناديق البريد او من يوصلون
الرسائل بين الاطراف بين الامريكان
والايرانيون هذا لا يعني في شكل من اي في
شكل من الاشكال انه تقدم او انجاز الى
الامام انا افهم كل هذا ربما يكون هناك
سؤال اذا لماذا صرح وزير الخارجيه
الايراني بهذه العمليه انا اعتقد هذا يعكس
جزء من الطموح العالي الايراني يعني من
يقرا السياسه الخارجيه الايرانيه فيها
يعني كم كبير من الطموح السياسي العاليه
الذي يريد كل شيء خارجي اليس كذلك طب هنا
دعنا فقط استاذي نعود الى تصريحات
المرشد الايراني او تاكيد المرشده
الايراني على علي خامنئي بانه
استئناف العلاقات مع السعوديه جاء نتيجه
لما سماها السياسه الايجابيه التي تتبعها
طهران لتعزيز علاقاتها بدول الجوار بعدها
نقلت صحيفه لوفيغاغو الفرنسيه عن وزير
الخارجيه الايراني قوله ان طهران والرياض
اتفقت على تطوير العلاقات التجاريه
والاقتصاديه بينهما وان تقارب بلادهم مع
السعوديه ليس مجرد اتفاق تكتيكي ودعنا
نتوقف سيد اليوم عند كلمه تكتيك التقرب
ليس مجرد اتفاق تكتيكي تتفق مع هذا
التوصيف
يعني في الحقيقه انا مما اعرفه من يعني
سيره العلاقات الدوليه ان الوصول الى اي
اتفاق بين طرفين بحجم المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وبحجم الجمهوريه الاسلاميه وبحجم
ما لدى ايران من طموح في نفوذ وفي يعني مد
هذا النفوذ سواء على شكل الايديولوجيا او
على شكل السياسه او شكل الاقتصاد وعلى شكل
التاثير الدولي هو لم ياتي وليد حقيقه يوم
وليله هو جاء من مخاض جاء من مفاوضات جاء
من شروط ربما غير معلنه لي ولك ولاده
المشاهدين لكن ما اؤكد عليه في الحقيقه ان
ايران لو لم تجد في هذا الاتفاق مصلحه
حقيقيه لها لما تقدمت الى هذه الخطوه
بمعنى ايران لا تقدم الى العالم هديه
لمساعده في استقرار المنطقه واستقرار
العالم لا هي تحاول الخروج من مازق لعل
اكبر المازق الذي تعيشه ايران هو موضوع
الملف النووي الايراني مع القوه الكبرى
والاسماء او ازمه عدم الثقه التي يعني هي
متبلوره وتتشكل ربما تخف وتقل باللحظه الى
اخرى لكن هي موجوده وهي مع المنظمه
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه هناك حاله عدم ثقه
ويعني تصريحات المسؤولين الايرانيين يعني
تؤكد ما اذهب اليه في هذه العمليه اذا
الاتفاق السعودي الايراني لكن ما تقوله
سيدان نقوله الى الاستاذ صدقيان في طهران
في الواقع ما يقوله المسؤولون الايرانيون
يبعث على التفاؤل اذا سمعنا الى تصريحات
المرشد الاخير
فالنتيجه نتيجه لما سماها سياسه الايجابيه
التي تتبعها ايران لتعزيز علاقاتها بدول
الجوار يعني هذا الحراك كله هو نتيجه هذه
السياسه التي تتبعها ايران مع دول الجوار
وهناك يعني
لا اقول تصفير ولكن سعي لتصفير المشاكل مع
دول الجوار بدات بالسعوديه هناك حديث عن
مصر ومساعي ايضا مع القاهره هل هذا هو
بالفعل النهج الذي
تنتهجه الان طهران مع دول الجوار في
المنطقه
هذا بالتاكيد نعم لان ايران وحكومه الرئيس
ابراهيم الرئيسي يعني منذ اكثر من سنه
وعندما دخل السيد الرئيس الى القصر
الجمهوري هو كان يامل في اعاده صياغه
العلاقات الايرانيه
العربيه بشكل عام والايرانيه الخليجيه
بشكل خاص وبالتالي ما رايناه من
اجتماعات تمت في بغداد وبعد ذلك قبول
ايران بالمبادره الصينيه
لاعاده العلاقات مع السعوديه واجتماع
وزراء خارجيه البلدين في بكين كل هذه
الاجواء
تعكس رغبه ايران ورغبه الحكومه الايرانيه
الحاليه في اعاده صياغه
العلاقات مع الدول العربيه ومع الدول
الخليجيه وهي تعتقد كما قال سعاده
المستشار هي تعتقد بان الامن والاستقرار
هي بطبيعه كل دول المنطقه لا ايران ولا
السعوديه ولا مصر ولا العراق ولا اي دوله
من الدول توزع الحلوى في ليالي الجمعه هي
تعتقد بان تعزيز العلاقات الثنائيه بين
ايران وبين الدول العربيه والدول الخليجيه
تحديدا يخدم الامن والاستقرار في المنطقه
ويخدم من ايران وبالتالي هناك علاقات يعني
نحن نتحدث الان كما قال عبد الله هيان عن
علاقات اقتصاديه مع السعوديه عن استثمار
مشترك هناك وفد برئاسه وزير الاقتصاد
الايراني زار السعوديه
للاجتماع بالبنك الاسلامي وهناك ايضا
ربما وفود ايرانيه اقتصاديه
وسعوديه سوف تزور البلدين وزياره سلطان
عمان الى طهران يوم يعني هذه الاجواء هي
اجواء التفاؤل ايران تريد ان تسير بهذا
الاتجاه
لو اضفنا صدقيان الى هذا الكلام الذي
تقوله على المستوى الاقليمي الشاعر على
المستوى الدولي وهنا اتحول الى الاستاذ
جوزيف في واشنطن هناك ايضا مفاوضات
امريكيه ايرانيه
كوريه جنوبيه لفك الحظر عن سبعه مليارات
من الدولارات من اموال ايران المجمده هل
نحن بصدد تحول في علاقات ايران مع الغرب
ايضا على المستوى المالي والاقتصادي غير
ذلك
نعم انتم محقون تماما فان اطلاق المراه
الارصده الايرانيه في كوريا هو ما تريده
ايران لكنني ارى ان ايران لا تفعل ما فيه
الكفايه للحصول على ذلك نعم هي تحاول
ازاله بعض الامور الشائكه مع الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه مع ما حول ما عملته
في السابق من نشاطاتها النوويه السريه لكن
على ايران ان تفعل ما هو اكثر من ذلك
اعتقد ان جو بايدن اراد التوصل اتفاق مع
ايران في العام الماضي تم عرض اتفاق على
الايرانيين في اغسطس وسبتمبر لكن ايران
رفضته
يعني نحن في سباق مع الدقائق الاخيره ماذا
انت تقول ايران لم تفعل المطلوب منها ما
هو المطلوب منها ماذا عليها ان تفعل لو
قلنا نقطه واحد اثنين ثلاثه على ايران ان
تفعل ماذا
ان تطلق الصراح بعض السجناء عليها ان تقلل
من دعمها لروسيا عليها ايضا ان توقف
الاضطهاد العنفي للمحتجين داخل ايران عند
ذاك هذا يمكن ان يمهد الطريق لاستئنافها
الاتفاق وايضا هنا عند ذاك الاسئله
المتعلقه بالوكاله الدولي للطاقه الذريه
تصبح قضايا ثانويه وليس رئيسيه
هذا ممكن لماذا لا تفعل ذلك ظهرا اطلاق
سراح السجناء وقف العنف ضد المحتاجين ضبط
العلاقه مع روسيا وغير ذلك
الامريكي المحجوز في طهران امريكا رفضت
ذلك رفضت صفقه تبادل السجناء وربط ذلك
باحياء الاتفاق النووي هذه نقطه اولى وقد
توصل الجانبان الايراني الامريكي الى هذه
الصفقه لكن الجانب الامريكي رفض تسويه هذه
الصفقه او العمل بهذه الصفقه وربطها
باحياء الاتفاق النووي النقطه الثانيه
قضيه
الوضع الداخلي الايراني الوضع الداخلي هذا
وضع داخلي ايراني ايران مسؤول عنه لا داعي
ان تعطى فاتوره ماذا يجب على ايران ان
تفعل في سياستها الداخليه ايران ترفض ان
تتدخل الولايات المتحده في شؤونها
الداخليه النقطه الثالثه قضيه الوكاله
علاقتي ايران مع الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه ان يعتقد بان اذا الولايات المتحده
سحبت يدها من الضغوط التي تمارسها على
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه ايران
بسهوله جدا تستطيع ان تطمئن الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذ برنامجها سلمي
والوكاله الدوليه لحد الان يعني منذ العام
2015 لحد الان لم تقل بان هناك لدى ايران
برنامج تسليحي او انه ايران تسير باتجاه
تسيح برنامج
تبقى هذه النقطه نقطه توتير
جوهريه للامن واستقرار المنطقه النقطه
نوويه هنا اعود الى السيد اليمين يعني
اكيد في هذه النقطه دائما على ايران ان
تفعل على ايران ان تفعل على ايران ان تفعل
ولكن ما الذي يمكن ايضا ان تقوم به او
تلعبه دول المنطقه لحل هذه المشكله
باختصار لو سمحت يعني من
المؤسف انا اعتقد دول المنطقه ليس لديها
ما تقدمه الموضوع هو احتقانات ايران في
علاقاتها الطرفيه في علاقتها بامريكا في
علاقتها بالاتحاد الاوروبي في علاقاتها
بالمنظمه الدوليه الى الطاقه الذريه في
علاقاتها بالقوه الاقليميه هناك قوه
اقليميه لديها مشكله مع الملف النووي
الايراني هناك اسرائيل التي تهدد بالقوه
وهناك الدول العربيه وفي طليعتها دول
الخليج التي يعني تامل ان يكون لها دور او
يد فيك ما يحدث في هذا الملف خاصه اذا
وافقت ايران على الرؤيه الامريكيه الجديده
ان يكون هناك اتفاق جديد وبشروط جديده اذا
المطلوب دائما يكون من ايران يعني هذا هو
موقف ايران او قدر ايران للاسف لان ايران
في الحقيقه وبكل تاكيد كقارئين للسياسه
الخارجيه الايرانيه ايران لديها مجموعه
مشاكل واحتقانات في علاقاتها الدوليه مع
اكثر من طرف
يعني الامور تتجه نحو حل برايك ام بالعكس
تعقيد اكثر
نحن نقترب قليلا قليلا نحو حل نعتقد ان
هناك صداما موجود في الافق اعتقد لا ايران
ولا الولا الولايات المتحده ولا حتى
اسرائيل تريد صداما اذا نحن نمر بمرحله
ليس فيها حل وليس فيها حرب كذلك يعني يعني
مرحله استقرار للوضع الحالي
ياس الوضع الحالي سيستمر لان ايران لا
تسارعوا لانتاج قنبله نوويه ولا هناك
بوادر صراع مع ايران لكن في ذات الوقت لا
تفعل ايران ما عليها ان تفعله لحل المشكله
واغلاق الملف مع الوكاله الدوليه الطاقه
الذريه ومع جيرانها لا تفعل ما فيه
الكفايه بهذا الصدد وصولا الى حل لا اعتقد
هي تستطيع انا بالنسبه الي الامور التي
حددتها انا ايران تعتبرها تخللا في شؤونها
لهذا السبب الوضع الراهن قد يستمر لعده
اشهر على الاقل شكرا جزيلا لكم شكرا
للدكتور جوزيف سيرينسيوني منه واشنطن عضو
المجلس الاستشاري الوزير الخرجه الامريكيه
السابق وشكرا لضيفنا من طهران محمد صالح
صدقيان الباحث المختص في القضايا
الاقليميه ونشكر ايضا ضيفنا من الرياض
الاستاذ سالم اليامي والمستشار السابق في
وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه شكرا لكم جميعا
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر لكم منا اطيب المنى والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]